coming through thick and fast god
goodness me
he is uh eating away right yup it's
surprising to see him do this
yeah um yeah okay meanwhile i'll try not
to
get distracted by magnus's meal
meanwhile on the board
it is equal material white's queen is
nicely placed
um it will be time in a moment to start
developing to get castled
if you look at the clock times as well
napoli actually he's gained a minute and
a half
since they started he's played every
single move instantly so he's deep in
his preparation uh remember these guys
have worked
together before um jana pomnicci has
acted as a second
for magnus carson so magnus knows what
the pogniacci's opening
tastes are how he studies the opening
stage
they know each other very well and um
i mean magnus here i'm surprised he
hasn't just castled his king and then
started eating
because that's the most obvious move in
this position it's the only useful thing
to do
magnus get your king castled and then
you can you can eat in peace